[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
[ __ ] so you guys went to vegas yep
no we didn't hell yeah
to vegas and like oh you never drove to
vegas before
wait let her finish her sentence for six
years
because i was trying to avoid airports
because are you lying to me
six years it was 2014. we'll wait
because we drove with them to vegas in a
van but we didn't drive
we didn't drive me driving oh yeah
that's cause we had a van
true we had a van last year remember
that i actually forgot about that
dude i feel like that's when i caught
coved really what in april of last year
i remember i was in the van and i don't
know where
i got [ __ ] crazy i needed the iv
[ __ ] remember we all got sick because
someone was sick in a van and it was
geo yeah that's that that made us all
sick that's it
my major immunity stronger is what
you're telling me thanks a lot you're
welcome
yeah you're welcome so we're all immune
to the vegas covid is what you're saying
vegas's version yeah yeah i think so i
think i caught it that time too because
that was the time we went did the iv
at night i was felt like i was breathing
out of a straw so i was like [ __ ] vegas
you can get anything let me give one of
these doctors that come over like
that are on call i called them oh yeah i
remember that yeah and they're like no
it's gonna cost a thousand dollars just
for the visit i was like [ __ ] you he had
like this brooklyn accent with
attitude i thought you're supposed to
care about my health after you're
dedicated to you son of a [ __ ]
and i could barely say that because i'm
breathing out like you were wearing that
hat too
and it's like i i hang up and i go to
urgent care the next day
and then uh they gave and i don't think
since covid wasn't like labeled or
really invented yet
they're like oh [ __ ] let me push thank
you let me put you on a respirator so
i'm there and i got to take a lot of
cool instagram pictures with this with
the respirator on
you get to vlog a little bit vlog a
little bit and then they're like oh [ __ ]
uh let me get an x-ray of your lungs and
they're like oh [ __ ] you have pneumonia
dude what the hell's going on
and i think it's literally kovitz [ __ ]
but
uh they just didn't have a name for it
yet yeah but this is also way
earlier than the supposed timeline maybe
you had covet 18. 18 and a half yeah
i didn't get that new new i didn't get
the update dude didn't you guys all get
sick when all of jk got sick in december
i did it i didn't i didn't either yeah
we did it actually because i
like that was the sickest i've been
because david got sick
you guys got to everyone but we didn't
we were [ __ ] up
it's so funny because there was someone
attacked so one of our fans tagged me in
this one video of this guy
making an impression and it says like
everyone
like oh my god i totally had coronavirus
back in december like i
totally did like they didn't have it
here yet but i totally had it and it's
so funny and then they tagged me in it
they're making fun of us yes me but we
did
you don't know us you don't know our man
i'm antibodies test you son of a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] prove you
probably right it makes sense because
like when new york was like blowing up
with kovid like la didn't really get
that crazy even though we're also a big
city and i think it's because
a lot of people had it in october
through december
that's my theory i believe if only we
could hear all the dumb [ __ ] you're
saying at home
i mean no one knows because we didn't
have tests
so then how was the drive to me it was
relaxing like i like
driving for long periods of time and
like i haven't been leaving my house at
all like
not to go to the store or anything so it
was nice to just even
get out of the house yeah and we got to
like make a pit stop at this place
called eddie world that has like all
this candy
it's so fun like this is my dream have
you been there right oh yeah yeah oh
yeah the urinals are games
was it orange on the way to vegas
the sky it was brown it was dirty brown
yeah and then it
did it clear it actually didn't really
it was just brown the whole way
like once we got to our friend's house
because we're staying at our friend's
house not on the strip
um it was even like kind of smoky there
too like it had
it had gone over there but then the next
day was clear blue sky it's like we
brought it with us and then it kept
going
well when i showed up it was like clear
blue and then it turned
smokey for like a day oh i think i was
day ahead of you guys i think it was
just the wind direction obviously but
yeah so
why'd you guys go out to vegas we were
possibly looking at properties
here's what i wanted to do you know what
i've never done before when i went to
vegas is not go to the strip
so i wanted to see if i could if you
could live in vegas
then not going to strip should be even
satisfying as well right
it's actually really easy to not go to
this trip yeah i liked it more
because like i think like you know
usually when you think about vegas it's
like this vacation you can't wait to go
there so you're like singing and having
a great time
some people feel that way not everyone
most people and then you're in the car
on a plane you're so excited
when you get their soul tunnel vision
right you're like i [ __ ] these [ __ ]
suburbs get the [ __ ] out of the way i
want to see the casinos
yeah but when you're using a different
when you have a different hat on
like i want to see the house yeah i'm
like oh [ __ ] like vegas is actually like
this
and then the red yeah the strip is
actually like this and then the city is
actually like this
and i'm like oh wait that's kind of like
like hollywood right like when you think
about like
other people how they think of l.a yeah
not everyone in la is an actor
just like not everyone in vegas is a
gambler or a casino or a
dealer or whatever so i'm like oh yeah
there's normal [ __ ] there's normal
industries there's dentists in vegas
there's veterinarians in vegas casino
workers need to get their teeth fixed
yeah everything's so new too that's what
i liked about it like it was like new
restaurants new like cool looking like
outdoor
patio bars like it was very very new
there's little touches too like i went
inside of a gas station
and there were there was slot machines
against the wall two guys playing slot
machines while drinking four loko
oh [ __ ] one of the saddest things i've
ever would they still make for
locos yeah probably in vegas no they
have it everywhere now no they're
illegal here no
no they they calmed them down or
whatever so they could re-release them
so they had to change the uh recipe or
something
yeah oh so they're not as low it's not
that loco anymore it's like two loco now
it's for mocos but vegas isn't the only
spot that i think people are visiting
like we have a lot of friends that are
checking out utah
yeah i have a friend who's buying in
texas colorado colorado
and then everyone in other states are
like get out of here californians
stop coming here well it's our turn
because everyone was coming here before
now we're going to you guys yeah how do
you like it
[ __ ] your freeways up how about that we
just weren't born during that time but
it happened we'll set fire to your rain
forests and [ __ ] that's what apparently
what we do here yeah
we got rainforest we don't have
rainforests we have dry forests
yeah desert if only they were
rainforests that was one part about
uh vegas that i'm like it's kind of cool
i'm like
nothing's even burnable it's already
been dry
it's all cement and rocks yeah try to
set a rock on fire but
you know what i noticed actually is that
it's surprisingly green in the suburbs
there
in the city yeah yeah they do a really
good job i was very impressed i
because we do all have that like ew but
you have to live in vegas
you know when you're what do you think
of this trip it's dirty it's grimy but
then you go out there and it's like
they're got trees
it's really nice and then they got like
mead and then they got
these like mountains that have like red
yeah red rock
during the um winter time so it's really
cute
i get dry fast though okay for me day
seven i was already
dehydrated that's true you need a
humidifier i was drinking a lot of
water and then i missed like one day you
missed a day of water
just not enough that's a lot you've been
missing a day here's a lot
oops i didn't drink water no it's not
like i didn't drink the whole day i'm
saying i
missed the same amount so like let's say
i have to drink double from la right to
to feel like hydrated
so if i drink la level waters out there
it's not enough
no i get dehydrated like a [ __ ]
yeah
if their tap's not all [ __ ] up like la
is damn is everything just better
sounds like it do they have earthquakes
there i don't think they do
or mosquitoes or mosquitoes that was the
selling point oh there's
no mosquitoes that's weird yeah it's too
dry for them
they shrivel up in the air new mexico
nevada arizona have the lowest species
of mosquitoes in the nation i'd rather
be in new mexico
and texas has the most species of
mosquitoes in the nation why new mexico
texas is interesting it's so humid bad
is it
yeah i never think it's so humid it's
humid oh yeah
texas is pretty bad casey and jess both
said they're like
oh it's way too humid it's pretty bad
during this
i didn't know they talked like time it's
way too humid have you not been to your
husband's home state
uh just once in the summer though just
kidding
uh you know like when he was sitting
here we were talking about moving to
texas he was like don't
yeah don't go don't i'm not going back
yeah he tells me that all the time
for sure but the hulk prices though
the prices and the taxes it's worth it
the prices of anywhere but california is
so awesome why is california all
[ __ ] up because they're trying to take
advantage it's almost like they're
trying to take advantage of the people
that there's a high population density
that's true well
i mean what sucks is that you go outside
of the main city
and then the prices are a little more
decent but it's still [ __ ] up
i'm not that decent still not that you
remember our cab driver
the yugoslavian guy he's like tell me
why
in victorville house is still more
expensive than vegas
no one [ __ ] cares about victorville
i'm like damn that's true
that is true oh hi california
hey victorville go [ __ ] yourself
we had nothing to say true and that was
and he has the most inspiring story
because he's like
i came here with nothing now i own three
houses
i drive cabs very expressive
yeah yeah yeah like i was talking to
almost every single cab driver
and then you know most of them aren't
vegas locals right like
there was even a british dude that was
like i've been here for 20 years
and then he's all like he lived in
huntington beach and he's like there's
no way he could have
raised his family out there he goes he
has a 5 000 square feet home and he's a
freaking cab driver and he's like
5 000 that's how it should be [ __ ]
mansion that's how it should be
it used to be that way in america
everywhere like you could have a blue
collar job and you could afford to have
a house it's not there's also so much
space like
they can continue to build houses
whereas here there's like
there's no more space they can't build
more houses well there are there is
space but they don't want to build
houses in the space
yeah you have your permits and
developments speaking of space you know
i just uh moved
to my little little garage space right
oh yeah and then because i'm moving like
i just had like all these boxes
everywhere and i had no time to cook
so thank goodness today's video is
brought to you by
daily harvest i love daily harvest i
don't really like to cook when i'm busy
i don't know anyone who does because it
just drives me crazy
and um the problem though is that like
when i get delivery and all that stuff
what ends up happening is like i eat
very unhealthy
so thank goodness for daily harvest
because guess what they deliver
delicious food built on organic fruits
and vegetables right to your door
it takes just a few minutes to prep and
i never have to question if the food i'm
eating is good
for me they never even use preservatives
added sugar or
artificial ingredients daily harvest
works directly with farms to freeze
their ingredients
at peak ripeness to lock in the
nutrients and the yummy taste with daily
harvest
there's an option for any time of day
smoothies breakfast
crisp smoothies for breakfast crisp
flatbreads for lunch or dinner and
comfort food for when the weather starts
to cool down like they're perfectly
roasted
harvest bowls and hearty soups
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to enjoy it helping
you reduce food waste which is really
important
daily harvest is also committed to
minimizing their environmental
impact they're in the process of
transitioning to 100
recyclable plant-based and renewable
fiber packaging that's dope that's cool
so we all deserve a break from cooking
with
daily harvest i can enjoy undeniably
delicious clean food without any prep
keep it simple with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com and enter promo code
otr to get 25 off your first
box that's promo code otr for 25
off your first box at dailyharvest.com
that's a good deal man 25 that's so good
yeah vegas is a good deal too man
yeah [ __ ] yeah bro isn't it crazy that
okay for what i'm paying it's adu unit i
live in a garage right
i'm just going to say i live in a garage
stop sounds better right
for the same amount i can get a
three-bedroom home and be
oh jesus isn't that crazy for the same
amount we were just talking about this
that we're paying for our mortgage
we could get a 3 000 square foot modern
modern house that's on that has a pool
that's overlooking a lake
they man-made a bunch of lakes and then
that lake has a beach that they made and
there's like three
private beaches and it's huge it has
like huge bathtubs and
it's open floor for the same [ __ ]
mortgage
wait how many square feet do you
currently have 1600
versus so it's like half oh [ __ ] yeah
well it has people that are listening
that's not from california or new york
or the east coast they're listening to
these prices like
duh duh that's normal right so the
national average for and
for for a home is about 200 feet to
three hundred thousand
my jaw is just like yeah la
is about seven hundred grand we share a
wall with people
two people on each side huh yeah like um
it's kind of it's weird shape but like
yeah one on this side and one in the
back oh
yeah but people from elliot know that if
you want to own a home it's almost like
a dream
yeah i never thought i could ever i
thought like oh it's just
uh i'm fine owning a home was for rich
people
like even my parents were like even when
it was cheaper
they're just like we're just gonna rant
for the rest of our lives
because even back then it was still
expensive compared to the rest of the
nation
but the way that we're all stunned when
we hear a cab driver owns three homes
is the way that yugoslavian one exactly
but the way it should be everywhere you
could realize the american dream
in outside of california that's what
exactly yeah
true yeah so please don't move to
california we're good we're talking no
move here we'll swap
no i'm staying in california no move
here because we're all selling we need
buyers
exactly thank you oh that's a good point
yeah isn't it crazy
there's there's a there's this exodus
that was started recently by all these
like business people and i mean joe
rogan and elon is a big example
and um i remember it started a while ago
even when we did our like i think our
first show
in austin i mean when they took us to
sixth street and they're like you see
all these food trucks they're like
a lot of california there's a lot of
california people here starting like
this whole food truck like craze
so it's like people been leaving for a
while they've been um there's a stat
that shows but i think right now during
this pandemic
it's like a huge exodus yeah it's like
double or like it's at a faster rate
uh for many many different reasons also
there's a case that's going on right now
that's kind of
uh well it's probably going to be a huge
case but
california is trying to claim that like
let's say youtubers right oh in that
case yeah so youtubers like
we get paid through google google
adsense
and then so they're saying that they're
entitled
to california taxes or like they're
we're entitled to pay california taxes
because google's in california yeah but
that's just like a really old law that
doesn't really make sense in a lot of
different ways
it's a california law specifically but
it doesn't make sense because
um for example let's say you're in texas
and you're a youtuber in texas
why are you subject to california taxes
it makes no freaking sense
and it's because like youtubers are like
people that make money through
online based off of silicon valley
companies they're moving in numbers like
crazy numbers they're moving outside of
california and california is like
no you owe us those taxes because those
companies are here
well so what happens when those
companies move there yeah they're just
driving people that's why
these companies are moving yeah they're
stupid
and it's not like we're employees to
youtube we're independent yeah
yeah that's just they're not going to
win i just love the state of california
instead of going like
hey we want to make this a more
attractive place for you to live or just
like
we'll we'll try to tax you even while
you leave our state they're being
conceded because
i read this one thing that they said uh
i think california if it was its own
country it would be i forgot the number
but i think it was like fifth largest
economy
yeah it is that's that's one of the
reasons why the government here feels
like
let's say these billion dollar companies
leave another one will prop up
in california so they're they're just
hella conceited but
what's stupid and what californian
politics
or politicians don't realize is this
pandemic has
empowered people to say i can live
wherever i want and still make money
i think it empowers people to go i can
be an
american and not have to be in
california well it gave business owners
too
this idea that they don't have to have
employees inside of a building to get
work done so
commercial real estate all this real
estate in california they're like i
don't need to be here
yep and they're you know shitty to small
businesses here
they're really shitty to small
businesses oh yeah
like we can't even open like right now i
think i think the gyms are suing the
state
of california yeah there's like a
class-action lawsuit with all this
like all the gyms are banding together
to stu to sue the state of california
because they felt like they've been
unfairly treated during this whole time
they even
try to [ __ ] their own government workers
so like
let's say um you retire with california
money right
and then um like you're a cop for so
many years or whatever
and let's say they move to like oregon
or washington or whatever at that point
uh whatever i forgot which state but
like let's say nevada you don't have
income state income tax right yeah so
you're no longer subject to that once
you become domicile there meaning when
you're full time living there
but then california lost a case where
they tried to still
tax the retirees and said that's
california pension money
so it should be taxed california style
but it's like
i don't know that that didn't really
play but that's how i guess desperate or
that's how they're like
coming after every meanwhile they shut
the state down the politicians of the
state still get paid every every month
easter still caught going to hair salons
and stuff exactly not wearing a [ __ ]
mask
yeah but then they tell us all to wear
masks and they tell us all we can't get
paid till later and
sorry yeah like your your friend told it
to me in a way i was like oh wow
i really see where he's coming from
because he didn't live in california
developed a app company a software
company outside of california but he
moved to california pursue youtube
was in was thinking about selling it and
then he was like wait a second
i have to pay how much tax like 15 of
his software company
uh just because he's in california when
none of the california resources helped
them build the software company because
this doesn't make any sense
it doesn't just by living here they try
to come after you because i'd rather pay
the tax to the state that i actually
developed the software at so he's like
[ __ ] that i'm gonna move to the bathroom
how would they even win like versus like
federal laws
you know like because talk to an la city
councilman dude
like you could be a business person
you're like hey why do you deserve this
because i built this whole company
out of state and they would be like
because
now pay us i mean that's literally
that's literally the leeway that's
honestly the leeway we get out here
so even not in pandemic times they were
mean to small business owners like it's
really hard to start
a small business and like like the way
they taxed you
and the minimum wages also yeah only
only massively rich people
can start a business here like
what people don't know is in la there's
so much red tape and bureaucracy
that if you did everything to the t by
the books
you're already like so much money in the
hole
and there's no way anybody can survive
building a business doing it the
the legal way yeah you're in california
you start a business you're paying 750 a
month just for your license
a month yeah your [ __ ] yeah well that's
probably a year yeah yeah
yeah but that's that's like in la it's
different so i'm talking mainly downtown
la or like
in that area yeah um the suburbs are
like just outside or different counties
are
are more lenient but i think if you want
to
make it in la it's it's really
[Music]
ridiculous
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you